as the race for the white house heads
into the post-labor day stretch
democratic nominee joe biden says he'll
resume
in-person campaigning making stops in
some key battleground states after
taking his campaign almost entirely
online
during the coronavirus pandemic new fox
polls show
the former vice president leading among
likely voters in three of those states
with a nine-point lead in arizona
a four-point lead in north carolina and
an eight-point lead in wisconsin let's
bring in wall street journal columnist
karl rove
he served as a senior advisor to
president george w
bush so carl we're about a week
since the republican convention closed
is it too early to
to look at the polls and say where the
campaign has shaken out
well i'd wait a couple of days more uh
we're we're now starting to get polls
that went into the field on sunday
night and i feel better about polls that
get did our sunday monday tuesday
wednesday of this week than i am about
polls that were conducted over the
weekend but
there's been a minor tightening of the
race
um but it's it's actually been going on
for some time if you look at the real
clear politics average the biggest gap
was just over 11 points
in that average on june 22nd and today
it's about 7.2 so there's been a
a tightening uh but it's been going on
for a while
well but uh that means there's still a
substantial lead nationwide for biden
and
less so in the battleground states but
you saw those fox surveys
nine points in arizona eight in
wisconsin i mean the president
won arizona last time right i want to be
cautious about something on these
state-level polls and these are fox
polls so we
we all have greater confidence in fox
polls but i i really
you know i'm looking at private data in
some of these senate races for example
in arizona
and in north carolina and they show the
race either
uh a small trump lead or or essentially
dead even we
saw for example a public poll in north
carolina this week
that had the race debt even and
we we have a lot more national polls so
we can construct an average and the
average of all those polls gives us a
better
sense of where the race is we don't have
as many state level polls now
is the president behind in states where
he should be ahead yeah arizona's one he
won wisconsin as well he won north
carolina as well
uh and and and he's got some work to do
but i'd be a little bit careful about
reading too much into one
individual state-level poll all right so
we'll let's see where that shakes out in
the next
10 or so days let's talk about this law
and order issue and the unrest urban
unrest the president's obviously trying
to make it a major
theme uh got joe biden on the defensive
where he had to at least start talking
about it but
is this making a difference in the race
doesn't seem to be in the polls
well i think i think the change in this
race is going to come by building
uh by building an issue upon issue upon
issue to a breaking point and so the
question is
will this help them get to that breaking
point this really boils down to a
question of judgment
uh is is joe biden too weak to address
this is joe biden wrong
in in failing to address it i mean it
was really remarkable the democratic
convention passed
an entire week without mentioning once
the lawlessness in american cities
i thought biden was smart to finally
come out and say i condemn in
very certain terms the lawlessness
that's going on in our cities people
must be punished
on the other hand he then turned around
and diminished it by immediately saying
well this is all
uh donald trump's fault he's responsible
for it yeah
which i think says to somebody in the
suburbs think about the people that we
that we have up for grabs in this
election they're sitting there saying i
sort of like what trump may have done
but i don't like how he handles himself
when biden goes and says it's all his
fault they say wait a minute it's not
his fault it's the fault of the
individuals
who rioted who you know picked up those
bricks and threw them through the
windows who took those molotov cocktails
and threw them
it's their fault not donald trump's
fault so
and it overwhelmed it if he simply left
it alone and said
you know i i condemn in no uncertain
terms what's going on in american cities
the police must uh hunt down those
people and they must be prosecuted
that would have been a lot better than
to to make it entirely political by then
turning and saying hey
it's really just remember it's donald
trump's fault
the the other uh one of the themes
related to this that the president is
pressing is this idea that
uh biden is weak that he's not tough
enough
to handle this kind of unrest of course
biden's response is
yeah but it's on your watch mr president
so who's weak and who isn't but i wonder
if the subtext here and the question of
weakness
relates to whether biden is going to be
strong enough to stand willing to stand
up to the political left
which has been driving so much on the in
the democratic party
i think that you're right and i think
that's the sub theme that we'll see
played out over the next seven or eight
weeks because
look he has done things that have just
astonished me he won the nomination
because he was a traditional democrat
and then immediately said bernie let you
and i sit down
and write a 100 plus page paper on how
i'm going to concede to you on
most major uh economic and social and
political and
military and national security issues i
mean that document the unity commission
report that they both signed off on is
an astonishing
uh surrender to the left of the
democratic party and
picks the most liberal member of the u.s
senate as his running mate has said
things that he wouldn't have said two
years ago three years ago
and maybe didn't even say a year ago
refused to say a year ago
let's i want to ask you about the jobs
numbers and the economy uh uh
this week because it looks like the
economy is recovering faster than
certainly i thought it would certainly
most people on wall street thought it
would is this something that
i mean we still are obviously have too
many people out of work
but uh it is recovering faster how
strongly would you hit this
issue if you were the president hark
back to how good it was in february
i'd be hitting it hard uh as as you go
into
september and into october i'd be
hitting it really hard because
you've got to make a bet he's his
campaign really has to make a bet
that as as we get further into the fall
coronavirus recedes from its position
as a as the major concern and that
people begin to turn their attention to
who is better able to reignite the
economy
this is where he has always had an edge
over biden and i
i read a little publication called the
dispatch each morning because they have
a little chart at the top
that shows the seven day rolling average
for cases
and the seven day rolling average for
deaths we are down
50 percent from the highs that we had
earlier this summer
on on cases and we are at one third the
level
of of deaths i mean not just not to
diminish the
how terrible it is that a thousand
people are so in weak are
are dying but we're down to a third of
where we were in may so
if that keeps continues then the economy
will be a bigger bigger
bigger issue in the minds of voters yeah
that's about a thousand a day
uh uh yeah no i know right i'm sorry no
no worries uh
uh just to prevent you from getting a
lot of mail carl